il y a cette astuce que nous faisons tous pour
passer notre journée nous prenons une boîte et dans
cette boîte nous plaçons toutes les horreurs du
monde nous fermons la boîte prétendons qu'elle
n'existe pas seulement certains d'entre nous nous avons perdu
notre capacité à faire semblant  pour un
opérateur spécial comme vous pendant un certain temps, qui êtes-
vous,
nous faisons le sale boulot que les
autres ne peuvent pas voici la partie amusante maintenant que
vous êtes mort, tout est effacé par plus de
casiers judiciaires, plus besoin d'être
arrêté juste pour être nu ou juste
des trucs habituels  tu sais être nu se
saouler des trucs décontractés donc on va tous
mourir on se fond pour disparaître regarde moi
j'espère que
cette mine
tu dois bouger honnêtement je ne
pensais pas qu'on irait aussi loin quel est le statut
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas Hey
on va tous
mourir autant le faire tant qu'on est en vie